bonsoir à tous nouvelle édition spéciale
de votre 19/20 bourgogne au lendemain du
deuxième tour des élections
départementales dans notre région seule
la nièvre reste à gauche hier soir la
droite a pris l avantage a repris
l'aventage d'un département de la
saône-et-loire dans le canton de louhans
la défaite du président sortant rémy
chaintron était attendu mais l'écart a
surpris même ses adversaires en tout cas
plus que les électeurs au contraire ce
matin par damien bouthillier est remis à
chaque
forcément un lendemain d'élection sur un
marché on ne parle que des résultats
surtout à louhans car outre le fait que
le département a basculé à droite et
rémi chaintron le président socialiste
sortant du conseil général était battu
sur son propre canton ici ça ne surprend
pas non pas du tout c'est tout à fait
normal compte tenu de des exactions du
gouvernement actuel passé tonnerre non
ça ne surprend pas
bon avec ça change c'est normal oui
c'est une suite logique alors forcément
du côté du binôme l'ump qui a remporté
le canton le marché ce matin petit goût
particulier il savoure surtout qu'il
s'impose avec 66 30 % des suffrages soit
deux mille six cent quarante voix
d'écart on pensait pas que l'écart
serait aussi important et c'est vrai que
s'en réjouir on a fait une campagne de
terrain de proximité je pense que ça a
payé une large victoire donc pour la
droite la suite logique d'une
implantation politique réussie petit
retour en arrière en 2008 anthony vadot
vient de prendre la mairie de branges il
est alors l'un des plus jeunes maires de
france et la fiche très ses ambitions
sept ans plus tard pari réussi il accède
au conseil départemental mais il va
devoir faire des choix déjà je continue
des activités de merde branger présente
la communauté de communes car le bresse
j'ai deux trois autres casquettes
intercommunal pour lesquels on va
s'arranger à ces luttes et là on
travaille déjà la mise en place des
nouvelles instances dirigeantes au
niveau du département une vice
présidence
les chaussons au report
discuter sur cet angle là rendez vous
donc jeudi à mâcon pour l'élection du
nouveau président et des vice président
candidat naturel à la présidence andré
accary ex chef de file de l'opposition
mais un autre nom circulait sébastien
martin président du grand chalon et lui
à givry contre le front national avec
près de 76% des voix stéphane robert
isabelle rivière
avec 76% des voix sur le canton de givry
sébastien martin est un conseiller
départemental nouvellement élu heureux
mais ce score peut-il pousser le patron
du grand chalon à la présidence du
département lui qui est en poste depuis
moins d'un an j'ai toujours été un
faiseur de rassemblement et d'union il
ya un an ça a été le cas chalon
aujourd'hui sur ce canton si je pense
que c'est le cas aussi on a su
rassembler très large avec 75 % au
premier tour pour maintenant
l'organisation du département je serai
aussi quelqu'un qui participera au
rassemblement et à l'union aujourd'hui
il appartient à andré accary de mener
les discussions il a été le leader de
l'union pour l'avenir de la saône et
loire et de cette campagne c'est à lui
de réunir les conditions du
rassemblement auquel je souhaite
pleinement participé pas candidat donc
mais il y à fort à parier que l'un des
hommes forts de cette nouvelle
génération de droite visera forcément un
poste de choix dans l'exécutif
départemental
dès l'annoncé de sa réélection hier soir
et l'officialisation de la bascule à
droite andré accary n'a pas voulu se
laisser distancer dans cette course au
perchoir l'ancien leader de l'opposition
n'a d'ailleurs pas tardé à légitimer sa
candidature andré accary nul doute à une
certaine taille mais vous serez le seul
candidat à l'élection du président du
conseil départemental jeudi écoutez je
ne sais pas à ce jour rien cet instant
en tout cas écoutez c'est un travail de
préparation depuis je vous dis de
nombreux domo années en tant que patron
de l'opposition alors peut-être que
évidemment des motivations nouvelles
peuvent apparaître ça c'est finalement
très humain mais en tout cas je pense
que le travail de fond va être connu une
certaine légitimité aussi devrait être
connu andré accary le sait bien dans la
coulisse la menace ni concurrence à
droite a plané un instant il devra
composer avec les ambitions des nouveaux
conseillers de la majorité pour
s'assurer le poste de président le vote
aura lieu jeudi matin
voici la nouvelle couleur politique de
la saône et loire vous allez voir en
bleu les cantons à droite en rose et
rouge ceux de la gauche eric sicaud avec
cette bascule le département c'est donc
en saône-et-loire co l'assemblée et le
plus profondément renouvelé oui c'est
logique mais les chiffres sont
impressionnants on compte seulement 15
réélu ce qui signifie que le conseil
départemental va accueillir 43 petits
nouveaux à droite des figures comme jean
girardon gérard collomb battu quittent
l'hémicycle et c'est andré accary donc
il n'a connu que les rangs de
l'opposition depuis son élection en 2004
qui devrait prendre la présidence mais
c'est bien sûr à gauche que l'on compte
le plus de départs dont ceux de
philomène baccot ghislaine colombo jean
paul drapier nathalie leblanc ou encore
joël martiaux plus globalement sur la
saône et loire cette défaite signe la
fin de l'ère montbourg après son propre
en retrait de la vie politique après la
cuisante défaite de rémi chaintron et
avec un thomas thévenoud toujours
contraints à la discrétion clair après
les victoires municipales l'an dernier à
chalon montceau saint-rémy cluny louant
ou encore saint marcel et avec la
bascule du conseil départemental la
droite a vraiment repris la main en
saône-et-loire l'yonne maintenant avec
l'élection d'un binôme au front national
grâce à 60 voix d'avant sur le
conseiller sortant de gauche
qu'attendent les électeurs de ces
nouveaux venus éléments de réponse avec
basile djaouti et claude heudin un
ras-le-bol des politiques une volonté de
changement voilà ce que dit avoir
exprimé les habitants de cette petite
commune rurale en votant en majorité
pour le front national
ici plus de deux électeurs sur trois qui
se sont exprimés ont donné leur bulletin
au candidate d'extrême c'est la première
fois de ma vie que je vois te front
national mais j'ai voté pour leur faire
peur alors deux tours j'ai voté pour
mais tout au deuxième tour peut-être
aussi un petit peu marre de toute cette
jarre est de 7,7 politique qui
effectivement ne nous fait plus avancés
nous fait pas rêver et pour moi je pense
que c'est un vote sanction point barre
les gens veulent que ça change
effectivement je pense qu'on est tous de
cet avis là on a envie que ça bouge un
peu on a envie de travailler et d'avoir
les moyens de pouvoir se payer certaines
choses oui surtout que ça change j'avoue
je suis bien triste quand même parce que
les gens ne se rendent pas compte tout
ce que ça implique derrière verrons bien
ici comme dans la majorité des communes
rurales du canton de villeneuve sur
yonne le front républicain n'a donc pas
fonctionné
les électeurs ont choisi de faire
confiance à deux inconnues de novices
qui ont su tirer profit du contexte
local avec une gauche et une droite
divisée mais aussi nationale nous
partons de rien ou de pas grand chose
nous n'avons aucune implantation locale
donc nous avons fait une campagne sur
des tout petits moyens sur le canton de
villeneuve par exemple nous étions une
équipe de quatre pour faire la campagne
donc ces essais les tout petits moyens
maintenant monsieur boulot il est
certain qu'il a payé la politique du
gouvernement une défaite historique
une terrible claque syrie le boulot a
vécu le pire moment de sa carrière
politique
battu dans sa propre commune le maire
divers gauche de villeneuve sur yonne
est évidemment amer mais dit aussi
vouloir entendre le message des
électeurs aujourd'hui on se réveille
avec la gueule de bois puisque le front
national est élu et les bisbilles locale
qui depuis sept huit mois 9 mois ont été
très forts très fratricides ont sans
doute conduit non seulement démobiliser
l'électorat mais peut-être aussi nous
envoyer clairement mais j'ai envie de
dire à tous un signal fort par un vote
de contestation
60 le nombre de voix qui a fait basculer
le canton de villeneuve sur yonne le
seul dans l'yonne mais aussi en
bourgogne à compter des conseillers
départementaux au front national
et dans ce département la droite détient
désormais 18 des 21 cantons
il y avait hier soir déjà deux candidats
à la présidence le sortant udi andré
villiers mais aussi le sénateur et
conseiller départemental ump jean
baptiste lemoyne mataly d'affaires et
christian mirabeau
andré villiers pour lui dit
jean-baptiste lemoyne pour l'ump deux
hommes pour un seul fauteuil au
lendemain du second tour les deux
prétendants au perchoir sont à la
manoeuvre pour remporter le troisième
tour le président sortant udi
s'enorgueillit d'être l'artisan de la
victoire éclatante de la droite avec son
appel au fonds république ça pèse dans
les négociations si le général qui
emmène ses troupes à la bataille revient
perdant une idée claire qui peut rien
demander donc là c'est pas le cas la
majorité a gagné donc ça ça quand une
position forte en tout cas pour pour ma
part à la métaphore guerrière son
adversaire lui répond par une métaphore
footballistique il juge le bilan du
président sortant très mitigé et veut
incarner un renouveau bien sentiment
d'abandon parfois et donc nous les élus
de terrain les élus locaux nous devons
être aux côtés des icaunais des
associations des entreprises pour les
aider à monter leur projet a attiré
l'yonne vers le haut ah c'est ça dont on
a besoin vous le savez la gia on
aimerait bien qu'ils rejoignent la ligue
1 l'yonne c'est pareil
jean-baptiste lemoyne n'est pas le seul
à vouloir incarner l'avenir de l'yonne
le jeune député ump guillaume larrivé
est en embuscade et s'invite dans la
bataille il feint de jouer les casques
bleus mais son soutien à andré villiers
transparaît assez nette en place il faut
que le sénateur le mois une prise
président villiers trouve la manière de
s'organiser pour faire du bon travail
maintenant je travaille depuis des
années avec andré villiers et je
souhaite pouvoir continuer à travailler
avec andré ville reid en filigrane de
tout cela c'est bien la suprématie à
droite pour la décennie à venir qui se
joue contre les deux jeunes
parlementaires ump guillaume larrivé et
jean-baptiste lemoyne
nouveau suspense intense dans l'yonne
est lilian melet avec ce duel droite
droite oui l'yonne illustre parfaitement
ce proverbe politique plus le gâteau est
gros plus il ya du monde tours le
conflit est né en 2011 quand une fronde
contre l'ump jean-marie rolland lui a
fait perdre la présidence au profit du
délit andré villiers mais une partie de
l'ump attend l'heure de la revanche il
ya d'abord eu de longues manoeuvre d'
approche au moment des investitures et
la rivalité a éclaté au grand jour sur
un certain nombre de cantons où deux
binômes de droite sont affrontés comme
jouanny saint florentin saint saëns ou
tonnerre et le sprint final vous l'avez
vu a débuté hier soir avec les annonces
de candidatures il est toujours
périlleux d'être régicide on peut
supposer que jean-baptiste lemoyne
n'aurait pas annoncé cette candidature
s'il ne pensait pas pouvoir fissurer le
camp d'en face voire même bâtir une
majorité ce qui s'est dessiné ce soir
avec le deuxième étage de la fusée un
soutien officiel de l'ump de l'yonne qui
pèsera lourd sur une majorité composée
de 16 ump 5 udi très divers droite et
même un modem andré villiers a annoncé
lui qu'il n'y aurait pas de réunion
préparatoire histoire de rappeler qu'il
a largement gagné les élections et qu'il
est donc le seul président légitime
il faut rajouter vous l'avez vu dans
cette histoire la place pivot de
guillaume larrivé qui a placé six élus
il nous disait hier soir vouloir
travailler avec le président andré
villiers les mots utilisés en sont tout
sauf un hasard donc on se résume c'est
un fauteuil pour deux tout le monde est
confiant personne ne se voit mais tout
le monde négocie donc à ce stade on ne
peut croire personne dans la nièvre à la
gauche résiste avec des dix cantons sur
17 c'est désormais le seul département à
rester à gauche en bourgogne et friable
par patrice joly le parti socialiste et
ses alliés comptent à peine 80 voix d'
avance régis guillon et cécile claveau
respect respect patrice joly peut avoir
le sourire son département résiste et
reste en rose comme depuis 60 ans une
victoire pour le ps et pour des
sympathisants issus du terrain alors que
par le passé nous avions essentiellement
des candidats issus du parti shas liste
là la nouvelle reconfiguration gros
dégroupage vous redécoupage des cantons
nous a conduits à faire appel à des gens
qui avaient une autre sensibilité
politique de gauche qui se
reconnaissaient dans nos valeurs et qui
ont accepté de
rentrer en compétition avec nous
l'assemblée départementale compte
désormais vingt conseillers de gauche
disent de droite et 4 sans étiquette
pour le ps nièvre une victoire oui mais
sur le fil patrice joly en tire les
conséquences on se doit d'être dans un
département comme le nôtre dans une
démarche de rassemblement nous sommes là
pour travailler ensemble et je voudrais
leur dire aujourd'hui rassemblement de
l'ensemble de ceux qui peuvent être
utiles au développement de
l'agglomération de la fille de nevers et
de l'ensemble du territoire
départemental
c'est l'appel que chance aujourd'hui
pourquoi pas se réunir bien entendu
essayé de travailler ensemble sur des
projets sur d'autres orientations
si ça peut améliorer les choses nous
sommes partants nous sommes prêts à
collaborer pour le bien-être du
département évidemment pour faire gagner
la nièvre puisque c'est notre objectif
la nièvre un bout du monde et surtout ce
matin un îlot rose entouré par des
départements qui eux ou sont restés ou
ont viré en bleu
voyons le cas de la côte d'or la droite
détient 14 cantons sur 23 avec une
progression en milieu rural comme à
montbard ou encore à nuits saint georges
dans ce dernier canton détenu depuis
plus de dix ans par la gauche le
conseiller divers gauche sortant a donc
connu une défaite amère et surprise
bintou sidibé tiphaine fighter
nuits-saint-georges chef lieu du canton
du même nom est devenu hier soir lundi
symbole du renforcement de la droite
dans le département une défaite à
laquelle pierre alexandre privolt
conseiller général sortant ne
s'attendait pas du tout l'élu compter
sur son bilan de onze ans pour se faire
réélire de retour dans le café où il ya
quelques mois il avait lancé sa campagne
le candidat divers gauche cherche les
raisons de ce désaveu
c'est une élection qui a été très
politisée au niveau national et que moi
j'ai fait une campagne locale sur les
compétences du département sur le
collège sur une roue sur nos maisons de
retraite sur nos crèches et je pense que
les beaucoup d'habitants ont voté contre
le land et donc j'allais dire je suis un
dégât collatéral pour dire ça comme ça
le vainqueur c'est lui hubert poullot
aujourd'hui ils étaient accueillis en
héros par ses amis avec sabino valérie
dureuil ils ont réussi à arracher un
fief emblématique de la gauche en
côte-d'or et c'était bien là l'un des
objectifs de leur candidature ramenez
nuits saint georges dans le giron de la
droite le nouveau canton nuit une nuits
saint georges qui est composée bien sûr
de son ancien conscient anciens
territoires plus une partie du canton de
givry qui a disparu un potentiel de
développement et à des équipements qui
sont nécessaires dans l'avenir et ce
canton était difficilement acceptable
d'être dans l'opposition du département
pourquoi parce qu'on considère que le
développement s'assure plus facilement
dans des réflexions qui sont menées par
la majorité par une politique du
département et qui porte ses fruits au
niveau d'un canton et puis bien sûr de
ses habitants cet après midi françois
sauvadet avait réuni ses troupes au
conseil général à ses côtés celles et
ceux qui ont permis à lui des ieg l'ump
de s'ancrer un peu plus dans le
territoire
dans les cantons dijonnais la gauche se
maintient et voit même une nouvelle
génération socialiste émerger pauline
ringenbach et amélie doit y rencontrer
trois rencontres et trois d'entre eux
nathalie c'est l'heure du débriefing au
deuxième étage de la mairie de dijon
après deux semaines d'élections
départementale assez mouvementée
nathalie koenders élu à dijon 2 hamid el
hassouni à dijon 3 font partie des
nouveaux visages socialiste de la
capitale des ducs entré en politique en
2008 lors des municipales nathalie
koenders prendra désormais place au
conseil départemental
c'est la première fois que je me
présente sur mon nom sur mon nom propre
parce que c'est vrai que mon les
élections municipales on est toute une
équipe avec une tête de liste donc voila
c'était une c'était important pour moi
de pouvoir me présenter sur mon nom
c'est grâce à la gauche que maintenant
aimé 1 50% de femmes ont siégé alors
qu'on était 13% à 1 14% avant donc c'est
important pour notre pays pour la
société en général et puis pour la
côte-d'or en particulier
hamid el hassouni lui aussi en place
depuis quelques années à la mairie de
dijon apprend petit à petit tous les
rouages de ce milieu notamment aux côtés
de pierre pribetich élus du grand dijon
si le qualifie de père spirituel mais
n'y voyez pas de connotation religieuse
mais c'est vrai qu'il a depuis quelques
années
tendance à me prodiguer des conseils
et on voit le résultat aujourd'hui je
pense que c'est quand même le résultat
d'un travail de collaboration
invité sur notre plateau ce midi céline
maglica élu à dijon 6 siégeait déjà au
département et à 39 ans elle brigue
désormais la présidence du groupe
socialiste
c'est vrai que au conseil départemental
j'étais jusque là la plus jeune
je crois que ça ne sera plus le cas ra
plus jeune que moi nouvelle génération
politique oui sans doute de toute façon
il faut un faut un renouvellement face
et bien de trouver l'équilibré entre le
entre les deux une nouvelle génération
d'élus socialistes qui doit assurer la
relève si la gauche veut conserver à
terme son fief dijonnais
vous étiez avec lui hier soir aussi pour
la soirée électorale de france 3
bourgogne je vous propose de revoir les
déclarations marquantes de cette soirée
à gauche comme à droite commençons par
le ministre du travail françois rebsamen
ce qui est plus inquiétant ce soir c'est
cette poussée cette vague du front
national qui monte qui monte si on n'y
prend garde ce parti qui est à part dans
la république risque d'emporter les
remparts républicain et de faire
basculer l'europe voilà c'est ça qui
m'inquiète ce soir à cet instant il faut
que le gouvernement
change de change de cap voilà c'est une
sanction très forte manuel valls pourra
pas nous dire mardi à l'assemblée
nationale qu on ne change rien le
gouvernement est aujourd'hui dans
l'échec donc soit les résultats arrivent
désormais très rapidement soit il va
falloir dare-dare trouver une nouvelle
orientation à la politique
gouvernementale
on a quand même un ancrage territorial
qui est bien posée nous allons continuer
il va qu'on se développer de plus en
plus donc non ce n'est pas une défaite
est donc si on n'entend pas le message
qui est passé par les électeurs qui
disent nous on est dans la panade vous
ne vous occupez pas de nous et en plus
les pratiques politiques sont à changer
dit on va être candidat à la présidence
du conseil départemental est parti aux
régionales après ça me paraît dangereux
donc là là il ya un travail de fond que
moi je suis prêt à faire avec mes amis
et j'y prendrai toute ma toute ma place
au revoir je pense qu'il faut aussi que
la droite ne soit pas trop confiante
dans une victoire qu'elle n'attribuerait
qu'elle-même verdon le parti suisse ne
changera jamais j'entendais tout à
l'heure avec une petite impatience quand
il est dit il faut tirer des
enseignements des scrutins le premier
enseignement est est ce que le premier
ministre va s'en aller parce que le vrai
problème aujourd'hui du mal de vivre des
français de cette élection de ce soir
c'est quand même bien la gifle qui est
donné par rapport à une politique
nationale c'est pas simplement des
enjeux locaux après des départementales
et régionales en fin d'année sont déjà
dans toutes les têtes eric elle les
premières déclarations n'ont pas tardé
dès hier ah oui il faut dire que le
paysage politique a nettement changé a
pas moins de quatre départements de
bourgogne franche comté ont basculé
désormais la droite en détient 6 sur 8
forcément cela aiguise un peu plus les
appétits pour les régionales alain
joyandet candidat ump a déclaré a été le
premier à se réjouir du résultat en
prenant bien soin de féliciter tous les
élus des rangs de la droite alors tous
n'apprécient pas surtout en côte d'or
lui dei qui soutient évidemment françois
sauvé des concurrentes directes d'alain
joyandet a renvoyé celui ci dans son
département de haute saône dont il
aurait mieux fait de s'occuper au lieu
de le laisser à la gauche il faudra en
tirer les leçons conclut le communiqué
et certains à l'ump comme le dijonnais
françois xavier
pour demande des sanctions contre le
sénateur côte-d'oriens alain houpert
soutien d'alain joyandet a accusé
d'avoir faire perdre le canton de talent
au présentant des dissidents à part ça
bien sûr tous prônent l'union et puis
pendant ce temps à gauche françois
patriat lui aussi à intégrer à son
vocabulaire les quatre départements
francs-comtois on l'a entendu dans notre
édition de 13 heures il se donne un mois
pour se décider à se présenter at il dit
il veut sans doute vérifier l'état de
ses troupes parmi les militants
socialistes et puis il ya eu cette
rumeur qui voulait qu emmanuel macron
soit la tête de liste socialiste ici ici
même donc rumeurs qui l'a fermement
démentie à beaune ce matin non il ne
sera candidat nulle part mais selon nos
sources cela lui a bel et bien été
proposé à suivre donc jusqu'en décembre
le ministre de l'économie était donc en
côte d'or ce matin chez atol emmanuel
macron a vanté les mérites des lunettes
connectés 100% française est lancée la
semaine de l'industrie reportage de théo
soumande et jean louis saint tin
le problème quand on a perdu ses
lunettes c'est qu'on est obligé de les
retrouver pour pouvoir les chercher
cette phrase de l'humoriste gustave
parking a peut être inspirer les
ingénieurs d'apple qui ont inventé les
lunettes connectés je suis un petit peu
tête en l'air donc lorsque je vais poser
ma lunette et puis qui est lentement il
veillera journal dessus avec mon
téléphone je vais pouvoir la bip et est
donc la retrouver et puis parce que je
suis toujours effectivement tête en
l'air aussi à l'intérieur de ma lunette
je peux avoir un petit bouton poussoir
qui va me permettre de faire bip est
aussi mon téléphone et ça c'est une
fonctionnalité qui jusqu'à présent était
plébiscité par tous ceux à qui je les
montre et l'innovation a été présenté à
emmanuel macron en janvier dernier au
consumer electronics show de las vegas
le ministre de l'économie avait alors
promis de venir plus tard visiter
l'entreprise à beaune promesse tenue ce
lundi à l'occasion du lancement de la
semaine de l'industrie quand on a créé
ce site henri mai 2007 on est parti de
zéro sur l'atelier de montage et donc on
a créé au fur et à mesure ses seize
emplois qui permettent de faire tourner
cuisine
je dirais en trois huit et
l'investissement total en robotique
aujourd'hui on a plus d'un million
d'euros la priorité notre action c'est
de réindustrialiser le pays et la
réindustrialisation
c'est à la fois leur relocalisation de
forces productives ce qu'a réussi à
faire atol mais c'est aussi la
transformation de cette industrie la fin
d'un clivage qui n'a plus cours entre
l'industrie et les services et la
définition justement nouveaux usages par
une innovation permanente
emmanuel macron a également annoncé une
nouvelle loi pour l'été destiné aux pme
au numérique et à la relance des
investissements privés des réformes
nécessaires d'après le ministre pour
déverrouiller l'économie française et
accélérer la reprise
le 19/20 continue d'édition nationales
après la météo attention aux rafales de
vent l'info en bourgogne également dans
le grand soir 3 et demain dès 9h50 dans
bourgogne franche comté matin très bonne
soirée sur france 3
le